Elon musk's X is worth
71.5% less than when he bought Twitter
says Fidelity so Fidelity is not like a
you know a regular uh company it's a
multi- multibillion dollar company with
a lot of money under
management here we go Elon Musk X
formerly known as Twitter has lost 71 a
half% of its value since he bought it
according to Fidelity One of company
shareholders one of the company's
shareholders this decline comes just
over a year after Musk acire Twitter for
$44 billion and renamed it to x with
Fidelity estimating its current value at
around $12.5 billion significantly low
than musk's own October estimation of
$19 billion musk's ownership of X has uh
been marked by contoversy with hate
speech Rising on the platform after his
takeover leading to Major advertisers
like Disney Apple IBM uh severing ties
additionally X recently failed to block
a California law acquiring social media
companies to disclose their content
moderation policy so Tom
71.5% of X has dropped why do you think
that is and do you think elon's really
worried about this number I don't think
he's worried about it I'll tell you why
Elon M's X is worth 71% less than when
he bought Twitter interesting enough
Jeff bezos's x is also worth 71% less
cuz she's been giving away his
fortune I'm a comedian singer so um but
no Elon must saw this coming he came and
he bought this and when he walked in
there and what was he carrying the first
day he walked into Twitter uh sink the
kitchen sink I'm here to change let that
sink in right so there we go so he kind
of knew this would happen but you have
to remember this is a public stock
stocks go up and down as soon as and by
the way Disney apple and IBM and the
some of the things they're boycotting in
the backdrop in America is Dei kind of
getting you know get its fingers slammed
in the door a little bit
which means some of these advertisers
are going to be coming back and soon as
they come back as here but what is
happening right now is Elon Musk a Buy
and Hold guy when he buys things or is
he a builder he's a builder He is
building functionality we're seeing it
right now we're seeing things happen and
by the way Twitter's had outages there's
a thing about outage this week but just
remember he is currently running the
current Twitter with onethird the staff
that he did before and he's building new
functionality in it suffering with some
things but what's going on in the B in
the background is a stronger Twitter is
emerging and as soon as the corner turns
on micr subscriptions because he was
charging people for the blue check and
he's going to be charging people for
other things and he was a destination
for things like uh a Tucker Carlson show
so there's a lot happening in the
background while the pressure is on the
stock and the advertisers are away you
know what's going to happen as soon as
the advertisers step back and some of
these other subscriptions go all of a
sudden Elon Musk is going to make an
announcement and a quarterly report just
like he did with t Tesla now we moved we
sold a lot more cars than you thought we
did remember those announcements that
come oh he's got all these trouble and
you know you know full self-driving FSD
has got problems and he comes out well
there may have been problems but we we
we sold 30,000 more calls than we
thought
also what happens Tesla is up at 260 or
whatever it is the single most you
valuable Auto stock I don't think he
worries about this I think he's going to
make a comeback on it but more
importantly right now he's developing
and adding things to it Twitter is
getting more valuable from a technology
standpoint not less valuable so I'll
give you a little feedback Tom because I
agree with you for the most part it's
it's it's all about timing short term I
think this is a freaking disaster
imagine you buy a house for a million
dollars million a year later your house
is now worth
$300,000 let that sink in for a second
sink in Tom so anyone in the short term
would be like dude what the hell is
happening here now longterm I think we
all know that he's a Visionary he's a
builder I think he's going to build this
thing back up but let's not pretend that
whatever he touches whatever he does
just automatically turns the gold I
think we're all fans of Elon I think
we're all seeing what he's doing with X
formerly known as Twitter but this is
not a good look not not a good this is
not a good look and last point there is
some preced in here so you talked about
stocks going up stocks going down we saw
what happened to meta Facebook when f
Facebook changed their name to meta
Tanked tanked now they're up as high as
ever but they turned it around but their
business model didn't change and they
weren't telling advertisers to go
themselves so there is some uphill
battle here with Elon I think we all
like Elon Free Speech Advocate free
speech absolutist he's absolutely
trolling everybody right now he's
feuding with Mark cubin I think we all
believe in Elon but if this was your
company if this was your house and you
were down 70% in 14 months you'd be very
very weary I'd be nervous but I do you
have to cuz I take a step back I'm not I
don't know about the money I I know it's
bad but what he's doing for us as as
Humanity that we get to see now cuz dude
if you think about it if it wasn't for
him buying X right now would you be here
this whole Epstein thing you would have
heard it maybe once on CNN Fox would
have been touching on it and it would
have been gone thank God for him cuz bro
he cares about the people that we could
talk he he loves Humanity he wants to
give us a form and Adam do you think he
really I mean he cares about money or
does he does he care about Humanity does
he care about letting us talk and
letting us have these conversations so
you know what he's doing he's running a
501c3 nonprofit philanthropic
organization God bless you yeah we see
that like if there's issues on the
traditional social media you know
whether it's YouTube whether it's
Instagram what have you okay let's go to
x he won't censor that but if you're
trying to make money which a company is
supposed to be doing you know they're
not doing it well sash you would know
this I mean X is not a dividend stocks
this isn't Hilton IBM AT&T the classic
dividend stocks that used to pay mom and
dad to private compan not mean public
anymore
right right you know and but the day he
comes back out the day he goes and the
day this this all comes back home to
roost you know is he happy about the
value no is the advertisers leaving kind
of a pain in the ass did he want to get
on stage and says hey Bob Iger and
Disney go go off you know no he didn't
want to do that but you know what my
point is don't dance on his grave and
this thing I don't think people
understand what is coming back you know
look and what I keep saying is look at
Tesla Look at Full self-driving look at
the Innovation look at battery use look
at all the things that you're seeing in
Tesla that everybody else is doing look
Tesla is making contracts with everybody
else to be the gas station for the EVS
they sell so yeah real real dumb guy he
is he's selling razor blades everybody
else is making razors and so I I don't
think he's happy about this but don't
dance on his grave baby I tell you I
really don't think he gives a
that's what I really don't think he
gives a he's sitting there saying
you guys worry about the stuff tell the
story tell all the stuff that you guys
want to talk about um when you when you
trust yourself to know that you're going
to deliver and you've done it over and
over and over again your level of
confidence is so high that when people
second guess you it's almost like
because here's how life works I had a
meeting with you and I had disc
conversation together in Aspen one the
mornings right and I showed it to him I
said look here's how life Works in life
the first time you cast a vision that
you're going to win at the highest level
okay and you're on your peers what
happens like like sa is here is upstairs
right sa a friend of mine that you know
him and I used to sit at Denny's and we
would talk me him and another guy and we
would sit I'm like hey one day and one
day one day We're Dreaming dreaming
dreaming how do you know the other
person is real how do you know the other
person is not full of how do you
not know that a lot of people people are
full of right okay then you fast
forward then you talk a bigger dream
then your friends are kind of like yeah
so what are you going to do this now huh
look at this idiot he said where's your
car where's your money and then people
start working with you and then you sell
it to them then they quit on you you're
not going to pull it off you're not
smart enough you're not this you're not
you never why would I believe you
capable of doing this and who's right by
the way all of those guys are right cuz
you haven't proven to the marketplace
then it happens then those guys call and
some of them lie to your face and they
say what we always knew you were going
to make it yeah and those guys call and
they say what man I'm not going to lie
to you bro I didn't think we were going
to make it I'm not I was actually a
hater and you know the fact they did it
good for you but now you go on your next
run and those people now say what well I
know he did it before but dude there's
no way in the word world he's going to
do it again okay now you have to go sell
the newer people in your life and some
of the people that were in your past
life they're like no I believe this guy
so for example David sacks gets a call
for Elan guess what David says no this
guy's going to do it hey what do you
need Elon boom and then so the people
that are close to you your level of
reputation the marketplace they going to
come through goes Higher and Higher and
Higher and Higher and
Higher but every single time whether you
like it or not the second guessing
Community is going to show up and
they're going to keep second guessing
you and that's what elon's going through
right now and guess what Elon the
difference for him today he doesn't have
to prove that he's smart he doesn't have
to prove to the world that he's Rich he
doesn't have to prove to the world that
he's a cool cat he doesn't have to prove
to the world that he's a great troll he
just has to ask himself the question no
one in the world knows more about what
it is to build a trillion dollar company
again than this guy the question is does
he want to do it and knowing how he is
guess what the answer is of course he is
okay of course he is but he's going to
go through his uh experience of
whatever's going to happen here with
Twitter so if you like this clip and you
want to watch another one click right
here and if you want to watch the entire
podcast click right
here